we've got a voicemail number which you
can call anytime you want if it's 3 a.m.
and you're raiding the kitchen and you
want to call you can do it and many
people do now here's an interesting
voicemail that came in last night in the
wake of the New Hampshire results which
argues there is something other than Joe
Biden being a centrist that's good about
Joe Biden not doing well take a listen
to this David we should all be very
happy of how Joe Biden did yesterday in
New Hampshire this I think is probably
going to lose now should make everyone
very happy because of stupid Ukraine so
it can't be used just like Hillary's
emails to make him wear this yeah that
that is interesting which is we know
that if Biden is the nominee it's going
to be about Bowie Zuma it's going to be
about hunter Biden it's going to be
about all of those things and it's
certainly true that if Joe Biden is not
the nominee it takes those issues
completely off the table which we know
are going to be fodder for Republicans
and for Donald Trump if Joe Biden were
to be the nominee now we also have to
understand either way they will come up
with something there will be a Hillary's
emails hunter Joe Biden Purisima they
will come up with something no matter
who the nominee is it is if it's Pete
Budaj edge they are going to come up
with stuff if it's Bernie Sanders they
are going to come up with stuff if it's
Michael Bloomberg Wow they're absolutely
going to come up with stuff so while I
agree that it's good that the hunter Joe
Biden Purisima stuff not become a
distraction in the general election that
allows Donald Trump to continue
bamboozling people and deceiving and
lying and all of that stuff that he does
that's good they're going to come up
with something else and we're gonna have
to fight it one way or the other it'll
just be something different but I do
think that the caller is right on
today's bonus show we are going to talk
about how there are proposals to ban
fracking at the state level in a number
of different states and in a lot of
states it will have no negative
repercussions for Democrats in the
Senate and in the house but there are
some states in which
fracking bans may actually hurt
Democrats in some states and we're going
to talk about which those are and
whether that's a reason not to do it I
think you probably can guess where I
fall on that also
jussie Smollett has again been indicted
in Chicago over last year's false fake
fraudulent hate crime claims that were
actually a staged hate crime we are
going to talk about how it has all
unfolded and next steps there and then
lastly again Donald Trump is calling to
end the student loan forgiveness program
in his budget we talked a little bit
about Trump's new budget which is a
total fantasy earlier this week on the
bonus show we are going to dig in more
specifically now into student loan
forgiveness we're going to talk about
the economic impact of something like
student loan forgiveness how much it
would cost how Bernie would do it and so
much more don't miss today's bonus show
instant access is available to you at
the click of a button at the tap of your
mobile phone screen simply grab a
membership at join pakman.com coupon
code is available 20:20 now it'll save
you 66% beautiful you can also get
access to the bonus show by making a
pledge at patreon.com slash david pakman
show at the $5 or greater level I will
speak to you then and otherwise on
tomorrow's program crystal ball will be
joining me tomorrow and we will do an
analysis of what seems to be a possible
contested Democratic convention we'll
dig in detail to that and much much more